selbstbewusst und autoritär
mit der größten waffenschau seiner
geschichte feiert china den siebzigsten
jahrestag der volksdroge heime auf den
prüfstand ein neues verfahren soll
sicherstellen dass die qualität der
pflege dort objektiv bewertet wird und
gewaltausbruch im internierungslager im
nordosten syriens droht die situation in
einem lager für zehntausende terror
sympathisanten zu explodieren
wir waren dort
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers guten abend in allen
heute um 7 geben sie uns knapp 20
minuten für diesen nachrichtenüberblick
sport natürlich auch dabei mit norbert
lehmann einen schönen programm tor von
mir
china feiert den beginn der
kommunistischen herrschaft vor 70 jahren
mit gigantischer militärschau in peking
und trotz eines demonstrationsverbots
geht auch heute die demokratiebewegung
in hongkong auf die straße um klar zu
machen dass es aus ihrer sicht so nicht
weitergeht heute vor 70 jahren mal ruft
die volksrepublik aus dem armen bauern
staat von damals ist inzwischen eine
ökonomische und technologische
supermacht geworden längst folgt china
marktwirtschaftlich kapitalistischen
methoden ist aber noch immer ein
kommunistischer einparteienstaat
die partei regiert seit 70 jahren und
inzwischen wieder mit harter hand
heute feiert sie vor allem sich selbst
stephanie schöneborn jeder griff sitzt
jeder die militär parade ist bis ins
kleinste detail vorbereitet da sind auch
solche bilder kein zufall
chinas militär ist bereit
15.000 soldaten marschieren es rollen
modernste waffensysteme darunter auch
diese erstmals gezeigte
interkontinentalrakete die angeblich
innerhalb von einer halben stunde die
usa erreichen kann und eine der
mächtigsten waffen der welt sein soll
keine macht kann den status unseres
großen mutterland erschüttern und keine
macht kann den fortschritt des
chinesischen volkes und der chinesischen
nation aufhalten vor 70 jahren rief mao
zedong die volksrepublik aus unter
seiner herrschaft starben mehr als 50
millionen menschen in china wird er
heute gefeiert sowie alle großen
machthaber chinas vor allem aber steht
präsident jean ping im mittelpunkt eines
weltmacht und das will der präsident
empfing heute zur schau stellen
die militär parade solcher stärke zeigen
und das selbstbewusstsein des landes
wird immer größer dabei bleibt jener
eine autokratie ein land das seinen
folgten misstrauen die menschen werden
immer mehr kontrolliert und die
freiheiten werden immer mehr
eingeschränkt
von problemen und kritik will china
heute noch mehr als sonst nichts wissen
china will sich selbst feiern und
tschechien schickt noch mal in großen
lettern eine nachricht in die welt neue
ära steht da das neue chinesische
zeitalter hat begonnen zumindest für
blieb
während die staatsführung feiert
eskaliert in hongkong die gewalt
demonstrationen dort wollte die
regierung in peking verhindern und hatte
dafür tausende polizisten auf die
straßen der chinesischen
sonderverwaltungszone geschickt in
mehreren stadtteilen lieferten sich
demonstranten und polizei
die schwersten zusammenstöße seit beginn
der demokratie proteste vor fast vier
monaten
zum ersten mal wurde ein demonstrant von
einem polizisten angeschossen
ulf röller ist live für uns in hongkong
mit guten abend am ende eines tages
eines langen tages dort welche zeichen
haben denn beide seiten heute gesetzt
also die hongkonger regierung und ihrer
polizei wollten eigentlich sehr deutlich
heute machen dass sie hier alles im
griff haben die sicherheitslage und dass
sie die straße kontrollieren
deswegen haben sie vorher sehr massiv
deutlich gemacht wer heute demonstrieren
geht bekommt ärger und sie haben auch im
vorfeld des heutigen tages viele viele
leute festgenommen
die demonstranten dagegen wollten klar
machen dass sie immer noch kraft haben
zu 10.000 auf friedlich auf die straße
zu gehen dass es ihnen gelungen
sie wollten unbedingt diesen siebzigsten
jahrestag der chinesen quasi ein böses
vergiftetes geburtstagsgeschenk nach
peking senden dass sie weiter für
freiheit hier in hongkong stehen und die
radikalen bei den demonstranten wollten
wirklich kämpfen und so ist heute aus
dem tag der trauer ein tag der wut
geworden es war der brutalste tag bisher
180 leute sind festgenommen worden und
dieser tag wird die krise in hongkong
weiter verschärfen ein voller erfolg und
vielen dank
damit nach deutschland und zu einem
thema das generationenübergreifend
interessieren muss ob betroffener oder
angehöriger wer nach einem platz in
einem pflegeheim sucht hat bisher ein
problem denn verlässliche informationen
über die qualität der einrichtungen gibt
es so gut wie keine
das soll er neuer pflege-tüv der
krankenkassen händlern danach müssen
pflegeheime detaillierte angaben machen
elisabeth schmid und christina eglseder
haben sich das neue bewertungssystem
angeschaut
die caritas st marien pflege im
niedersächsischen nordhorn gilt als
vorbildlich beste noten nicht nur laut
aktenlage sondern auch von den bewohnern
wir werden hier so gut versorgt und
gepflegt also besser geht's nicht und
ich habe auch schon sowie zugenommen wo
es in den mehr als 13.000 deutschen
pflegeheimen nicht so gut läuft für
angehörige allerdings bislang kaum zu
erkennen
der alte pflege-tüv selber durchgefallen
da konnten die einrichtungen nämlich
mängel bei der wundversorgung etwa
ausgleichen beispielsweise durch einen
guten speiseplan
bisher war der pflege-tüv er eine farce
fast jeder hatte die note 1 mit diesem
neuen system bekommen wir und vor allem
die pflegebedürftigen und ihre
angehörigen ein besseres bild beim neuen
pflege-tüv übermitteln die heime selber
halbjährlich daten zu 15 kriterien wie
anzahl der stürze oder ausstattung der
zimmer an einer unabhängige
auswertungsstelle dazu kommt einmal im
jahr eine externe überprüfung durch den
medizinischen dienst der krankenkassen
inklusive befragung der bewohner
patientenschützern aber reicht das nicht
ohne ko kriterien kann es nicht laufen
wer bei der wundversorgung bei der
medikamentösen versorgung oder
überdurchschnittlich viel fixierung in
heim hat wer darauf fällt der kann am
ende nicht eine super einrichtung führen
und das ist schwierig herauszufinden
statt noten nun einen kriterienkatalog
den angehörigen erst einmal verstehen
müssen um einrichtungen zu vergleichen
nachzulesen sind die ergebnisse ab dem
nächsten jahr auf den internetseiten der
pflegekassen oder den aushängen in den
heimen
schlechte nachrichten für
pauschalurlauber die bei einem
unternehmen des insolventen thomas cook
konzerns gebucht haben sie werden hier
schon gezahltes geld nicht voll
erstattet bekommt ein sprecher der
zürich versicherung bestätigte dass
jetzt die versicherungssumme von 110
millionen euro werde zitat bei weitem
nicht reichen
der verband der reisebüros hatte
errechnet dass mehr als 300 millionen
euro nötig wären
wie viele kunden genau betroffen sind
ist nicht bekannt
zwei tage nach der wahl in österreich
hat ex vizekanzler und fdp chef heinz
christian strache seine politische
karriere beendet er strebe keine ämter
mehr an und lasse seine spd
mitgliedschaft ruhen sagte strache damit
wolle er schaden von der partei abwenden
strache war eine große mitschuld am
wahldebakel der rechtspopulisten gegeben
worden
wegen des skandals um das ibiza video
und zuletzt wegen einer spesenaffäre und
jetzt eine nachricht die aufhorchen
lässt unruhen und gefechte mindestens
zwei tote in einem flüchtlingslager auf
das die welt besonders schauen sollte
alkohol im nordosten von syrien
zehntausende kämpfer und sympathisanten
der terror miliz es vor allem frauen und
kinder sind dort untergebracht und es
gärt hass solchen hitze in den letzten
monaten sind mehr als 300 kinder
gestorben gegen epidemien aber auch
gegen den teufelskreis dass sich die
menschen immer wieder neu radikalisieren
kämpfen junge mediziner aus europa und
den usa
ihr job anspruchsvoll und hochgefährlich
ich habe sie vor ort beobachtet es gibt
kaum schlechtere orte für den start ins
leben
der kleine ahmed hungert am liebsten
würde er seine hand essen sagt die
krankenschwester
sie kommt aus den usa ahmed mutter
gehört zur terror miliz es alltag im
feldhospital von alkohol syrien
die deutsche hilfsorganisation cardus
improvisiert mitten in der wüste ein
paar container absolute
minimalausstattung und doch der einzige
ort der hoffnung gibt ich war die ganze
zeit aus angst um mein kind aber seit
ich hier bin bin ich ein bisschen
ruhiger ein kern sind die menschen doch
überall gleich sie haben träume und
ziele und kinder die sie lieben wenn man
sich das klar macht dann kann man auch
hürden überwinden zwischen uns langsam
aber immerhin das krankenhaus an einem
der brisantesten orte dieser welt stürme
solchen gewalt man muss erbarmen haben
und gleichzeitig angst 71.000 menschen
leben unter diesen umständen hier in
diesem riesigen lager und die
lagerverwaltung schätzt dass weit mehr
als die hälfte von ihnen glühende
anhänger der terror miliz es und zwar
immer noch wir werden beschimpft und
bespuckt als wir durch das lager gehen
die einen hier haben den ds terror
unterstützt die anderen sind vor ihm
geflohen
alle gemeinsam wissen nicht was jetzt
kommen soll keine perspektive nur staub
und elend nährboden des terrors so muss
man ihn sich wohl vorstellen warum sind
sie hierher gekommen
wir sind der islamische staat der wird
weiterbestehen er hat nur die umgebracht
die es verdient haben er hat uns auf den
rechten pfad geholt es ist wirklich ein
islamischer staat
ein einfacher zaun mit vielen löchern
komplett überforderte bewacher lange
sagen die kurdischen militärs hier geht
das nicht mehr gut
das ist wie eine tickende zeitbombe die
kann jeden moment explodieren die helfer
um elena wollen sich davon nicht
abschrecken lassen sie tun was ihnen
selbstverständlich erscheint als
mediziner als menschen die improvisierte
isolierstation um den kleinen
tuberkulosepatienten hier kümmert sich
die schwester ganz besonders für einen
kurzen moment in diesem desinfizierten
raum scheint der haster draußen ganz
weit weg
sie mögen unterschiedliche sprachen
sprechen aber sie verstehen sich doch an
entwicklung dort mit potenziellen folgen
auch für uns und jetzt das ende eines
deutschen justiz krimis lebenslanger
haft für acht mitglieder der
rockergruppe hells angels wegen
gemeinschaftlichen mordes
beziehungsweise wegen anstiftung zum
mord der prozess gegen die rocker
dauerte fast fünf jahre anfang 2014
waren die teils vermummten männer in ein
berliner wettbüro gestürmt einer von
ihnen erschoss dabei gezielt einen
26-jährigen kunden in finnland hat ein
mann eine berufsschule überfallen er
tötete eine frau und verletzte neun
menschen
augenzeugen berichten der angreifer sei
in der stadt kuopio ihm mit einem
schwert in einen klassenraum
eingedrungen
die schule liegt in einem
einkaufszentrum polizeibeamte schossen
auf den mann und setzten ihn außer
gefecht
das motiv und die hintergründe sind noch
nicht bekannt die opernsängerin jazz
begeisterte fans auf der ganzen welt
jetzt ist sie im alter von 74 jahren in
new york gestorben
als eine der ersten dunkelhäutigen
künstlerinnen konnte jesse normen sich
in der welt der klassik durchsetzen ihre
glanzvolle karriere begann in
deutschland antoine kurschilgen hat eine
große opern diva ihre sopranstimme war
gewaltig und gefühlvoll
[Applaus]
meine wenn ich dann auf die bühne komme
man kann doch sicher sein ich bin da
weil ich diese musik und sie liebte auch
mozart
die karriere von jesse normen begann
1969 an der deutschen oper in berlin
eine jahrhundert stimme jubelten die
kritiker mit großem repertoire wagner
verdi strauß die große oper war ihre
erste leidenschaft ihre zweite bar jazz
[Applaus]
ein weltstar ausgezeichnet mit fünf
grammys und der national medal of arts
einer der wichtigsten auszeichnungen in
den usa verliehen vom damaligen
präsidenten barack obama einer ihrer
größten fans und das beruhte auf
gegenseitigkeit
es ist schön das zu denken dass jemand
im weißen haus sitzt der gedichte liest
und musik anhört ich bin nicht ganz
einfach hat sie mal über sich selbst
gesagt aber das sei ihr egal eine echte
operndiva eben eine der besten der welt
[Musik]
sie wird uns fehlen jetzt kommt der
sport in der sendung knauber hat das
bist du ja leichtathletik wm in doha und
da deutschland die erste medaille geholt
bronze für europameisterin gesa
felicitas krause über 3000 meter
hindernis 1 in deutscher rekordzeit ein
wahnsinnsrennen gestern abend souveräner
sieg der neuen weltmeisterin briefs
chefcoach aus kenia und hinter
titelverteidiger kugeln aus den usa wird
krause nach einem taktisch sehr klugen
lauf dritte in neun minuten und 3,3
sekunden
mit dieser zeit ist die 27-jährige jetzt
übrigens die zweitbeste europäerin der
geschichte der umstrittene
leichtathletik trainer alberto salazar
ist von der us anti doping agentur für
vier jahre gesperrt worden
ihm wird unter anderem die anwendung
verbotener infusionen vorgeworfen dallas
ist chefcoach des nike orion projects in
den usa dem auch die deutsche
wm-hoffnung constanze klosterhalfen
angehört das trainingscamp in portland
seit 2001 werden hier spezialisten für
die lauf langstrecken mit modernsten
methoden und techniken trainiert ziel wm
oder olympia medaillen alberto salazar
wehrt sich gegen seine sperre auf der
homepage des projekts
er sei schockiert dass oracle projekt
habe doping nie geduldet und werde dies
niemals tun
constanze klosterhalfen gehört seit
april dem projekt in portland an
zu diesem äußerte sich im sommer im
aktuellen sportstudio dies klar bewusst
dass doch immer sehr viele negative
sachen mit in verbindung gebracht werden
aber ich bin da sehr unbefangen
hingegangen die 22 jährige hat sich klar
gegen doping positioniert deshalb steht
der dbv fest zu klosterhalfen es gab
bisher keine beanstandungen ihr
gegenüber
insofern wird sich hier starten für
constanze klosterhalfen kommt diese
unruhe zu uns seit sie startet damit
noch im vorlauf über die 5000 meter
heute abend zwei top auswärtsspiele
deutscher mannschaften in der champions
league bayern münchen gegen tottenham
und bayer leverkusen gegen juventus
turin und damit auch gegen weltstar
cristiano ronaldo der ein jubiläum
feiert zum 25 mal trifft er in der
königsklasse auch ein deutsches team und
hat bislang 26 mal getroffen
das war und jetzt feiern wir den 150
geburtstag der postkarte sie ist
tatsächlich so alt geworden trotz all
dieser digitaler konkurrenz heute vor
150 jahren führte österreich ungarn die
sogenannte korrespondenz karte ein platz
war damals nur für wenige worte mal
persönlich mal derb mal von unterwegs
wetter gut essen gut grüße aus so was
halt die postkarte war so was wie die
sms des neunzehnten jahrhunderts dabei
entwickelte sie sich immer weiter jetzt
landen auch digitale urlaubsfotos schon
mal im analogen postkasten schöne grüße
vom wetter herbstlich kühle aussichten
kommen gleich von katja hornuf aber ein
bisschen sonne ist glücklicherweise auch
mit dabei der hinweis noch aus
heute-journal 21.45 mit der kollegin
marietta slomka morgen an dieser stelle
freut sich petra gerster auf sie ich
danke ihnen ganz herzlich für das
interesse wünschen allen einen
angenehmen haben
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren in
bayern wurde es heute nochmal richtig
warm da stiegen die temperaturen zum
teil auf 23 jahre 24 grad
das wird sich jetzt allerdings ändern
mit dem tief nils das bringt viel regen
heran und über der nordsee können sie
bereits die nächsten regenschauer
entdecken jetzt in der nacht kommt der
dauerregen auch am alpenrand an bis
donnerstag können bis zu 50 liter regen
pro quadratmeter fallen
in diesem kräftigen regen sind doch
immer wieder gewitter zu erwarten nur an
den küsten von nord- und ostsee locker
die wolken schon auf da wird es dann
auch kühl da sinken die werte bis 4 grad
sonst bleibst deutlich milder mit 14 bis
10 grad
morgen zieht der regen dann weiter
richtung süden und es gibt einen
freundlichen streifen von der
ostseeküste bis zur mosel und von der
nordsee kommen die nächsten regenschauer
heran das sind auch gewitter dabei
und die erreichen bis zum abend ungefähr
ostwestfalen die temperaturen liegen
morgens zwischen 12 grad in husum und 17
grad in passau oder auch in freiburg und
am tag der deutschen einheit beschränken
sich die regenschauer im wesentlichen
auf einen streifen von der nordseeküste
bis zum erzgebirge wechselhaft gibt es
danach weiter schönen abend noch